I had a full body thermography done. It showed that my immune system is low. I'll send you the report so you could advise. Well, I want to comment on that right there because I know they lots of times they're radiologists where they look at fat. They'll say your immune system is low because maybe you have some increase heat or decrease heat around the thymus.
That's just be honest, you cannot tell a person's immune system is low by looking at a thermometer. So that is just silliness, sorry, so it doesn't mean your immune system isn't low, but you can't look at a thermography and say your immune system is low, so I wouldn't trust them.
Based on the above, I was going to try a 48 fast. Well, I think it's a bad idea. So 48 fast, ever we've talked about this. Fasting more than 24 hours increases IGF1 levels. Well, for a person who doesn't have cancer, that's a good thing. You want to increase IGF1 levels. That's increased growth factors that will increase overall health, doing longer fasts can be really good for you.
But if the person with cancer, you really don't want to raise IGF1 levels. So I personally would not recommend over a 24 hour fast with anybody with any history of cancer.
You could do a fasting mimicking diet, which is a five day fast, but you're not eat a true fast. There's been tons of studies on the fasting mimicking diet that shows that it does not raise IGF1 levels. So it's safer cancer. It's a very good for cancer.
So the fasting mimicking diet is a five day food plan. We sell it other practitioners sell it. We have in the store. It's called the FMD. I have multiple videos on FMD. That would be the maximum that I would say to do.
We start to copy animals now. I should have started to copy animals a long time. But copy animals are good for everybody. Unless you got, you know, rectal cancer, you can't insert the animal to there's different different people that, you know, they just can't do copy animals.
But everybody else should be doing copy animals. So yes, I think that's a good idea to do anything else I can do to boost my immunity.
Really, all your supplements, your moods, supplements, everything that are going to boost your immunity plus coffee animals because what is there a logical stimulation of your immune system is your parasympathetic. So anytime you can stimulate parasympathetics.
Coffee animals are a great way to do so. Also look on the blog here. Look up parasympathetic, sympathetic. I and you'll see all the vagal nerve stimulation exercises and the sympathetic calming.
The metabolic exercise, the calm, the less encephalon, where the part of the brain, where the sympathetic are housed.